Today's lecture, if you
look at the online guide,
is supposed to be about
Martin Luther King,
the establishment of
the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference,
as well as the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee.
And I'm going to do my absolute
best to get us to that moment.
We should be able to do it.
But because of the lost
lecture due to the midterm,
this is sort of my last
attempt to get us back on
schedule. So I want to
canvass a slightly larger
period. Today I plan on
discussing some critical
aspects of the Montgomery
bus boycott and the
integration of Central High
School in Little
Rock, events from '54,
excuse me, '55, '56,'57.
By doing so, it allows me to
talk about a very important
aspect of the movement that
I've made an allusion to
already once or
twice in the course,
but you'll certainly see it
coming up again--time and
again over the next
few weeks of the course,
and that is the issue of
respectability. Just as we
can look at the
late nineteenth
century's--century
and issues of,
of being civilized, of
having proper sort of normed
middle class behaviors is
very important to at least
the black
leadership elite class,
being respectable, being
the right kind of person is
fundamental to understanding
a lot of the civil rights
struggles. Now let's
look at the Montgomery bus
boycott. And I'm going to
presume that in the history
of the Montgomery
bus boycott and the
desegregation of
Central High School,
this is now American History
101 that you should have had
the gloss of it when you
were in high school. And
I'm sure you didn't get
much more than the gloss,
and I'm sure the gloss was
wrong. [students laugh]
But what I want to do is
actually give you--you know
the mythic
narrative of these things,
which is there for a reason,
and I want to give you some
background details that are
important to consider. So
as far as the
boycott is concerned,
Montgomery bus boycott,
there's a standard history
that has become
mythic. Rosa Parks,
the tired seamstress,
refuses to give up the seat,
her seat, on the bus in
Montgomery and she gets
arrested. Martin Luther
King comes swooping in to
her rescue and then rises to
the national scene with his
leadership of the
yearlong boycott,
thirteen-month
boycott, that would,
that would ensue shortly
thereafter. I was looking
at the syllabus last night
and realized I dropped a
reading for you. And I want
to encourage you to go back
and look at it now. I'm
referencing it right now. I
believe it's pages three
fifty-two to three sixty-one
in the Manning Marable
anthology. It just,
I just, it just slipped
out of the syllabus by
accident. And
in those pages,
you'll see Jo Ann
Gibson Robinson,
a prominent black
woman in Montgomery,
explain her version of
the events around the bus
boycott. Just even knowing
about Jo Ann Gibson Robinson
changes the story of the bus
boycott. Robinson was part
of a cadre of, of
middle-class African
American women, sort of
think of the club women from
the early, late-nineteenth
century that I talked about
a few weeks ago, who had
already organized into a
force, the Women's Political
Council. These were women
who were well-educated,
college educated,
some of them teaching at a
local college. These were
sort of the elite. Although
they didn't nece--they
weren't rolling in money,
these were the elite in,
in black Montgomery. The
Women's Political Council
with Jo Ann Gibson
Robinson's leadership,
she's one of the
key figures in it,
has already gone to the
black ministers in town and
the city government in town
about their frustration over
the way that blacks were
treated on the buses and the
way they were treated in
stores downtown. "Economic
boycott" are the words
they're floating around.
They wanted to try to
develop the courage in the
black community to get a
boycott organized. The
Women's Political Council
keeps running into dead ends
in various places.
They might get a meeting,
but the meeting,
frankly, where men were in a
leadership position, would
be rather condescending to
the women: "That's very
sweet of you to come in,
but, you know, we'll
take care of things now."
Nothing would happen.
Now the Women's Political
Council actually tries to
organize boycotts of the
buses around
issues of crisis,
and this is when other
people get arrested for
refusing to give up their
seat. Now if you look at
the selection in the Marable
reading and Jo Ann Gibson
Robinson's recounting of the
bus boycott and Rosa Parks
arrest, you might find
something striking. When I
was actually going back
and looking at it tonight,
like, "God, how did I forget
to include this?" If you
scan it, as I
did several times,
for Martin
Luther King's role,
you will only see King's
name mentioned once and,
quite literally, in
the second to last line,
I believe, of this reading.
Now this is an excerpt,
granted. Things might have
been dropped out. But if
nothing else,
metaphorically,
it's actually a very
important point. King was
not there, not engaged
in the organizing moment,
early organizing
moments of the bus boycott,
what would turn into the
bus boycott. Now why bother
telling this story? Just
because it's inserting a new
cast of characters? Well,
maybe that's part of it.
Maybe because it was
pointing to the role that
women played in
the movement,
had always played in the
movement. That's certainly
part of it as well.
But another part of it's
important to know, is
that the bus boycott was,
its success was incumbent
upon many different
factors. It wasn't
just King's charisma,
although we cannot ever
discount King's charisma.
Part of it was dealing with
an already established and
organized,
politically organized,
black middle class, as
basically the organizing is
done through their
women. There's already,
then, a network of
activists in place,
upon which King's
charisma could be displayed,
or through which.
I don't know what the right
descriptor is. It basically
starts to muddy up the
narrative of the civil
rights movement, this,
this amazing moment of the
movement. But
there's more to the story,
always more complicating
factors. Rosa Parks was
arrested, there's
no doubt about that,
but it wasn't as spontaneous
as history makes it out to
be. Now Parks is
refer--referred to as the
mother of the movement,
partly because of her
indisputable character. She
was as proper as one could
imagine. She
was hardworking,
she was civil, she
was law-abiding.
She's the perfect
person to become a "victim,
of it were, of an insane
system. If you can't treat
this person
properly, there's something
fundamentally wrong with
your system. We know that
about Rosa Parks. But what
we don't know is that she'd
been trained at a civil
rights institute the summer
before she decides
to get arrested,
the Highlander School
in Tennessee. Parks was
reluctant to go, but she
had friends who were already
committed to the movement
in very public ways,
convinced her to come
along. And while there,
she's meeting
with white radicals,
labor activists,
Communist Party members,
other black activists
from around the country,
and learning about
nonviolent civil
disobedience, learning about
different strategies in
which to create a crisis
for the sake of the greater
good. So Rosa Parks, now
she's not a fire-breathing
radical. She's
not at the vanguard,
but she is trained and she's
prepared for that moment
when it actually happens.
That's dropped out of the
history. Another thing
that's dropped out
of the history is,
she was not the
first woman--or person,
but in this case,
woman-- to be arrested for,
you know, violating
etiquette on the buses,
certainly not in Montgomery,
certainly not in other
places.
In fact, a few weeks
before Parks was arrested,
a young woman named
Claudette Colvin was
arrested in a similar
situation. The boycott
almost emerged, organized
by the Women's Political
Council, and the boycott
almost emerged revolving
around Colvin's arrest. She
was a straight-A student;
she seemed to be of
impeccable character. If
you're treating a
child like this,
how could you treat any--I
mean how could you claim to
be humane? It
turns out though,
that very quickly discovered
that they couldn't use her,
Colvin, as a vehicle
for their boycott,
because this straight-A
student of unimpeachable
character,
unmarried of course,
also happened to be
pregnant. She was not
showing at the moment.
People in Montgomery,
black activists, realized
right away there's no case.
That they, they cannot make
a case around her because of
Southern traditions that
would say that she was
immoral for her, quote,
"condition." And that would
have been the word that
would have been used. And
they knew that they could
not make a convincing case
if they have someone
with such failed standards,
such immorality
in her system,
that she'd be the worst
example for these women
activists. The activists
understood that being
respectable in a very narrow
band of what that means was
absolutely critical.
Respectability is so
important to the movement,
because anything that
transgressed a line of being
respectable could be used to
justify a
denial of some sort,
whether it's legal, "You
can't come to this school,
whether it's
psychological, "I can,
I can limit your entire
existence in terms of
possibilities," or
whether it's physical,
"I can kill you." Let's
just go back to Brown v.
Board and the reactions
to it. I already told you
about Melba Beals'
experience as she's about to
be raped when she's
twelve years old,
but we can see in reactions
in other places in the
South, systemic reactions,
the extent or the ways in
which there was a logic that
blacks had to behave just
right because the stakes
were so high. In the wake
of Brown v.
Board, in July of '54, the
White Citizens Council is
formed. I'm
simplifying a lot,
but think of it as the
upper-crust Ku Klux Klan.
Business
leaders, white males,
prominent figures in
these Southern towns that
organized, Southern cities,
organized themselves,
fund Klan activities, making
sure in a variety of ways
that there would not be an
integration or destruction
of their social order.
Economic warfare happens
across the South
with, with city leaders,
White Coun--White Citizens
Councils battling it out
with radicals, the
most proper radicals,
like Jo--Jo Ann Gibson
Robinson. Governments start
responding. This
arcane little caveat in,
in--excuse me, loss of words
here--in how governments
interact, the Doctrine of
Interposition. It's a weird
phrase. The Doctrine of
Interposition is invoked by
Southerners, saying that the
federal government had no
power to interfere in
states. This goes back to
1832 or something like
that. Completely ignored
little tidbit attached
on some bill somewhere.
Southern governors and
governments start invoking
the Doctrine of
Interposition,
saying the federal
government had no power to
interfere, interfere in
states. Federal officials
from the South, members of
the House of Representatives
and Senate, gather together
and all through the Southern
Manifesto, saying that
Brown was a clear abuse of
judicial power. Only
one member from a federal
delegation in the South
refused to participate,
and that's Al Gore, Sr.
from Tennessee. Wait,
I might be blanking on
that. I think--Kefauver.
Kefauver, yeah, thank you.
and Lyndon
Johnson. Was it three?
It was three.
Well, there you go, it was
three. Well done. Where'd
you learn this history?
Did you take this class last
year?
No, I just wrote a
paper on postwar America.
Excellent. Well done.
You were trained by
somebody well. Anyway,
but thank you. There
was--All but three of I
think maybe a
hundred people.
No, there were
representatives who didn't
do it, including Rayburn.
Oh, well hell, apparently I
don't know the history at
all.
There were other
representatives.
This is why it's so
dangerous to talk to
students at Yale. The fact
is massive--the Southern
Manifesto is a declaration
that Brown doesn't carry
weight. There's going to
be a negative response of,
of, of resistance, and
the phrase becomes known as
"massive resistance"; that
the South is going to refuse
to proceed forward with the
logic coming down from the
Supreme Court. People start
becoming targeted. NAACP as
an organization
becomes targeted by Southern
legislatures, saying the
NAACP had to reveal its
membership list in order
to stay in business as a,
as a, an organization, had
to reveal who was in its
membership. This is
basically a death warrant to
the organization
in some states,
and to people who were, and
to people who were members.
If you were known to be a
member of the NAACP and
worked in
Mississippi, well, you know,
the boss might decide you
don't have your job any
longer, for some other
trumped up reason. And it
might actually get you
killed. Violence takes on
gothic proportions in
Mississippi more than any
other place. In '55,
several black leaders urging
blacks to vote
were murdered,
one on the local
courthouse lawn.
The president of a local
NAACP chapter was shot down
when he ignored the order
to remove his name from the
voting register.And then
of course there was Emmett
Till, fourteen-year-old,
fourteen-year-old boy,
sent from Chicago to
stay with his family in
Mississippi. There are many
different versions of what
happens. The allegation is
that he whistled one day,
hanging out
with his cousins,
that he whistled at the--a
white storekeeper's wife
when she walked past.
Others have countered saying
he had a, he had
a stutter, and,
you know, he would often
lisp as a result. What
actually happened at
that moment is really
inconsequential. What
happens later is of great
consequence. That
night he's abducted. He's
beaten. One of his eyes is
gouged out. He's wrapped in
barbed wire and tied to
farm equipment before being
thrown over a
bridge. When they find him,
his body is sent
surreptitiously up to
Chicago. His mother insists
on having an open casket at
the Chicago funeral and the
images shock the country.
There's a clip here, that
opens up with Mose Wright,
who was Emmett Till's uncle,
who makes a very famous
declaration going into
court. And he points out
the people who came to
get Emmett Till from him,
which meant he could no
longer live in Mississippi.
He vacated right away in
order that he might live to
see another day.
When the sheriff came and
told me they had found a
body at [the Tallahatchie
River near Glendora,
Mississippi], and wanted me
to go and identify the body,
which I did.
And we found the body,
which it didn't have on any
clothes at all.
The body was so badly
damaged that we couldn't
hardly just tell who he was,
but he happened to have on a
ring with his initials,
and that cleared it up.
The body was shipped home,
back north to Chicago where
Mamie Till Bradley insisted
on an open casket funeral,
"So all the world
can see," she said,
"what they did to my boy."
Jet magazine
showed Till's corpse,
beaten, mutilated,
shot through the head.
A generation of black people
would remember the horror of
that photo.
I believe that the whole
United States is mourning
with me, and that the death
of my son can mean something
to the other unfortunate
people all over the world.
Then for him to have died a
hero would mean more to me
than for him
just to have died.
When you heard the
narrator, Julian Bond,
talking about a generation
would never forget this
murder and the image that
appeared in Jetmagazine,
he wasn't exaggerating.
One of my former colleagues,
her father's family
from, was from Louisiana,
from a rural
part of Louisiana,
and I was--he was visiting.
We were having lunch
together, dinner together,
and Emmett Till came up. I
can't remember why. But
he said he was fourteen or
fifteen years old when
Emmett Till was murdered,
and he knew then that he had
to leave the South as soon
as he could, and in fact,
he never went back. And he
said he has never forgotten,
and he knew there was no
hope for, as he put it,
"a black man in the Deep
South." Now there
was a court case.
It was an all white,
all male jury. The jury
deliberates for sixty-seven
minutes. One juror said
later, it wouldn't have
taken so long if they hadn't
stopped to get a soda. And
the jury defines--finds the
defendants not guilty,
although everybody knew who
did it. January '56, one
month after Parks' arrest in
Montgomery, Look magazine
publishes an interview of
the Till defendants in which
they state for the record
that they had in fact killed
him. Now this is the most
spectacular and perhaps
egregious case of violence
gone unpunished, but
there were other episodes,
and some of them happened as
a direct result of Brown. I
already again
related to you,
the attempted
rape of Melba Beals,
but violence is endemic.
In fact, this is one of
the great stories of the
nonviolent civil
rights movement,
is that it was horribly
violent and it's rather
shocking that it did not
become more violent at any
given moment.
Now thinking of violence
and respectability and
narratives of the civil
rights movement leads us to
the Little Rock Nine.
And I have to gloss over the
history very quickly for the
sake of time. Melba Beals
goes on--the person who was
twelve years old when
someone loses his mind and
tries to attack her--goes on
to come--become one of nine
teenagers who are eventually
selected by NAACP activists
to integrate Little Rock
Central High School. They
are focusing on Arkansas
because it seemed to be one
of the most progressive
states in the South on these
issues. Other parts--other
school systems in Arkansas
had actually
already integrated,
but Central was
the most important,
most visible high school
in the state. The nine who
were selected were
amazing students,
academically gifted, coming
from the right families who
comported themselves in the
right way. Otherwise they
would never have been
selected. Without going
over too much of the famous
integration of Central High,
I'll point out a
few things that are,
that one needs to remember.
The students are selected to
integrate in '57. There's
fierce local resistance.
The governor, Orval Faubus,
calls in the Arkansas
National Guard to
prevent integration.
President Eisenhower,
very unhappy about the whole
scene, sends in the 101st
Airborne to force the issue,
and he does it not because
he believed in integration,
but because he believed in
the federal government's
right to assert itself.
This is a states' rights
versus federal rights issue
for Eisenhower. The troops
ushered in the students
after they had already tried
to integrate the
school before,
but were harassed by mobs
outside of the building.
The students--the, the
troops could go with the
students up to the, the
door of the classroom,
but in the classroom,
or in the bathroom,
or in the cafeteria, all
hell broke loose. One
student had lye
thrown in her face,
almost permanently blinded.
Students would talk like
being in the bathroom, and
then going to the bathroom,
and then paper towels lit on
fire being thrown overhead
when they were helpless.
They were attacked,
books were thrown
down, food poured on them,
but they could not respond.
The one student who did
respond got kicked out,
at which point they said,
"One nigger down;
eight more to go,
trying to get these
students out of the school.
Houses were bombed,
people were shot--shot at,
folks lost their jobs. Now
think about all this. What
is it that's being
asked of these children?
And they are children.
Going back to Melba Beals,
there's a few items
from her diary entry,
New Year's Day in 1958, that
allow us to ask some pretty
important questions.
Four different items,
selected from a
longer list is,
one, "to behave in a way
that pleases Mother and
Grandma," two people who
were very central in her
life. "To keep faith
and understand more of how
Gandhi behaved when his
life was really hard."
"To pray daily for the
strength not to fight
back." And the entry that,
the resolution that she,
that she put as number one,
was to "do my best to stay
alive until May 29th,"
the end of the school year.
I mean, think about
it: NAACP activists,
grown women and men, are
making sure the children
stay--are to stay in school,
despite the violence being
vet--being visited upon
them. And it's very fair to
ask, is it appropriate for
sixteen-year-olds to feel
the need to write in
their diaries that the most
important New Year's
resolution is to "do my best
to stay alive" until the end
of the school year? What
are the adults asking the
children to do for the sake
of the movement? It's a
case--it's a question that
would come up quite angrily
in 1963 in the Birmingham
crisis. Now one final note
about the school year and
Little Rock. What we
don't often hear about,
what we basically never hear
about Central High School
history, is that
the govern--I mean,
because it's a
triumphant moment,
right? So the governor was
so upset about the public
relations disaster that
accompanied the school's
integration, that he decided
to shut down Little Rock
public schools
the following year.
The integration
of the school,
this great moment of civil
rights victory of American
exceptionalism,
lasted one year,
and the public schools were
shut down. Why don't we
know this part of the
history? You know,
there's something really
maybe too tantalizing about
these nice narratives of our
past. We can be ashamed of
the shortcomings of
our predecessors,
but by keeping the
story clean and simple,
we can also be proud that
our predecessors ultimately
made the right decision
and did the right things.
In short, the civil rights
movement has been sanitized,
because it ultimately
casts a great light on the
American
character; that, you know,
the American character
can take its lumps,
learn from its mistakes and
then do great things. The
civil rights movement has
been cast as a great moment
of American exceptionalism
when we all summoned the
courage to do
the right things,
regardless of our
political positions,
where we are in the
country, et cetera. Well,
that's just one big fat
lie. Only a minority of
folks rose to the
challenge, and accepted it,
and pursued it. Martin
Luther--Martin Luther King's
history is a case in
point as far as rising to a
challenge, and as far as
what happens when a history
is sanitized profoundly.
King is raised in a
tradition of ministers. His
father and grandfather run
the most elite black church
in Atlanta. King has a
rather raucous adolescence
and college years.
He and his buddy go around
trying to run competitions
about, you know, who could
"deflower the most girls" in
the language of the
day. He does receive a
religious--religious
calling,
however, goes off to
seminary and then gets a Ph.
D.
at Boston University, a Ph.
which scholars discovered,
much to their great
disappointment,
about two decades ago,
that he had plagiarized
parts of it. King,
though, these things aren't
widely known at this moment
in time, '55, is seen
as a real future star,
and he gets a
job in Montgomery,
heading the Dexter
Avenue Baptist Church,
which is, much in the
tradition of his father and
grandfather, the most elite,
sort of upstanding and
politically conservative,
quiescent church,
in that particular
city. He's relatively newly
married. He and his wife
Coretta have a newborn. He
wants to settle into a nice,
quiet pulpit and do nice,
quiet work. Well, there's
already things shifting
around on the ground,
with the Women's Political
Council agitating for
an economic boycott,
trying to find a test case
to boycott the buses. And
the group of black ministers
in town are very important
people, and a group called
the Interdenominational
Ministerial Alliance. A
ton of syllables there. The
Interdenominational
Ministerial Alliance is
feeling pressure from
Women's Political Council to
do something. King as a
minister is automatically in
that group. And then as
things start heating up
towards what will
become Rosa Parks's moment,
King is thrust into the
limelight in a way he never
wanted. Parks gets
arrested. King is sent as
an emissary or sacrificial
lamb--really more of the
latter. The Montgomery
Improvement Association is
formed. This is going to
be the group that's going to
organize the boycotts. King
does not want to lead it.
The other ministers, who are
deeply skeptical this thing
will actually work, figure,
"King just got here. He's
young; he'll rebound when
this thing blows apart.
We'll put him out front."
King couldn't say no. He
fought, fought, fought, but
he couldn't say no. He'd
already resisted the
invitation to head the local
NAACP for the sake
of his children's,
his child's safety.
Anyway, on December 5th,
the night before the
boycott's set to begin,
King is still resisting
the urging of the ministers,
and finally relents, and
writes out some notes on a
piece of paper. Goes to
the pulpit with about ten,
fifteen minutes to
prepare and says,
in part, the following.
Now the audio is,
is not great, and I'll
tell you what he says,
but I want you to hear the
energy of the moment during
the closing moments of his,
of his speech.And we are not
wrong; we are not wrong
in what we are doing.
If we are wrong, the Supreme
Court of this nation is
wrong.
If we are wrong, the
Constitution of the United
States is wrong.
If we are wrong, God
Almighty is wrong.
If we are wrong, Jesus
of Nazareth was merely a
utopian dreamer that
never came down to Earth.
If we are wrong,
justice is a lie,
love has no meaning.
And we are determined here
in Montgomery to work and
fight until justice
runs down like water,
and righteousness
like a mighty stream.
Oops!
"If we are
wrong," he says-- "And,
and we are not wrong in what
we are doing. We are not
wrong. If we are wrong, the
Supreme Court of this nation
is wrong.
If we are wrong, the
Constitution of the United
States is wrong.
If we are wrong, God
Almighty is wrong.
If we are wrong,
Jesus of Nazareth is,
was mer--merely a utopian
dreamer that never came down
to Earth.
If we are wrong,
justice is a lie,
love has no meaning.
And we are determined here
in Montgomery to work and
fight until justice
runs down like water,
and righteousness
like a mighty stream."
You can tell, the
audience is going crazy,
energized by this young man
who's come out of nowhere.
But think about what he's
saying here. He invokes God
and Jesus. It's what, what
one would expect of course,
but he invokes in the
first part of this quote the
Supreme Court and the
Constitution. He's evoking
law. King is not
invoking anything radical,
as a matter of fact. He's
invoking the Supreme Court
and the Constitution. He's
invoking those very things
that made citizens citizens
in the United States after
all, and perhaps that is
the thing that made him so
radical. Anyway, the
movement takes off and the
boycott holds
together. It's a,
it's a remarkable history,
although it wasn't the first
boycott, bus boycott.
The movement holds together
for thirteen months before
the Supreme Court forces
the integration of the,
of the buses. These are the
same thirteen months when
massive resistance is rising
up throughout the South,
the same thirteen
months when Emmett Till is
murdered, and the same
thirteen months when the
strategy for Little Rock
becomes articulated and
starts to gain traction.
A period of astonishing
change.Now King
rises to prominence.
He's traveling all around
the country constantly
raising money during the
bus boycott. They need
resources and money to pay
for gasoline and cars that
are all shipped down to
Montgomery to make this
thing work. But he's not
doing it by himself. He's
aided by two people who are
rather important. One is
Bayard Rustin, who I've
already mentioned before.
Earlier part in his
life, member of the Young
Communist League,
a draft resistor,
someone who was arrested
on morals charges for being
caught in the back seat
of a car with another man.
He's gay. Often recognized
as one of the great
organizing minds of the
freedom struggles and labor
struggles of the
twentieth century,
but because of the
politics of the day,
hampered by his
sexuality and,
and by his Communist past.
But Bayard Rustin is in
King's corner, you
know, telling him,
"Do this, do
that. You know,
follow this particular
path." King is also aided
by Ella Baker.
And by the way,
Rustin and Baker are finally
getting the attention that
they deserve from, from
amazing histories that have
been written about five or
six years ago. Ella Baker,
a long-time activist who
worked for Unemployment
Councils in the
Great Depression.
Certainly was affiliating
with folks who were
Communist. Older woman who
becomes hailed by a younger
generation of activists
who are just about to become
known for being one of the
most important leaders in
the movement. Baker
starts to work with King and
advising him as well.
I'll come back to them in a
moment. As the
boycott nears success,
we see violence quite
clearly. King's house is
bombed. Other people
are being shot at. It's a
bloody mess. But Rustin
sees in the success and the
violence as a catalytic,
catalytic moment of
possibility, and that the
question becomes not so
much, "How great
was this moment?"
but, "What can we do to
capitalize upon it? What
can we do to sustain this
organizing energy? There
needs to be an
organization."
And he calls on King
to bring together other
leaders, and, and
essentially religious
leaders, to gather together
to think of the next steps.
And out of that comes
the Southern Leadership
Conference, is what the plan
is at least. The Southern
Leadership Conference,
bringing together,
you know, the great
leaders in the South,
African American, to become
organized to have sustained
change. Well, King makes
a decision that infuriates
Rustin, and they have a
very tense relationship in
general, Rustin recognizing
King's astonishing gifts as
a speaker and King
recognizing Rustin's
astonishing gifts as an
organizer and political
thinker. King never likes
the fact that Rustin is gay
and talks condescendingly
to Rustin about it. Rustin
always underestimates,
in King's opinion,
the role of religion in this
movement. So Rustin calls
it the Southern
Leadership Conference,
and King changes
its name under,
with sort of fiat, to
the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference.
And the SCLC, the Southern
Christian Leadership
Conference, becomes one of
the most important civil
rights
organizations for the next,
really for the next twenty,
thirty years. King's
popularity skyrockets
with the success of the bus
boycott. He's increasingly
drawn away from the pulpit
as he travels about trying
to raise consciousness and
funds. And by
January of 1960,
having barely been in the
pulpit at Dexter over the
previous few years,
he leaves. He's not
ministering to that church.
The SCLC, what he now
heads--[student sneezes and
he coughs] excuse me,
bless you--the SCLC is now
focusing on leadership
training and citizenship
education. Now as the
SC--SCLC emerges out of
King's success,
wrapped up in his charisma,
it creates stress in the,
in "the system." You see
stress often embodied in
intergroup squabbling,
something you'll see a lot
throughout the 1960s. An
established organization
like the NAACP is not too
thrilled about the SCLC
arriving on the scene,
because they're competing
for the same people and the
same dollars, scant
dollars. In fact,
Medgar Evers, who's the head
of the Mississippi NAACP,
who joins the
SCLC, this new group,
was told he had to choose.
You either pick with SCLC or
you pick the NAACP. He
stays with the NAACP.
Now the NAACP is already
under stress. I talked
about the fact that its
rolls are being opened up by
Southern legislatures,
but there's also stress
internally through
people like Robert Williams,
military vet from
North Carolina,
who becomes fed up with
events in his town where
he's the head of the
local NAACP chapter,
and calls for retaliatory
violence. He's kicked out
of the NAACP by the end of
the 1950s. So the NAACP is
struggling with
rising, percolating spots of
militancy,
people leaving the,
leaving, leaving the
message behind at the NAACP.
And now this new group
appears on the scene that
might pull away other
supporters. The important
thing to know I
guess from that,
I suppose, is that neither
the SCLC nor the NAACP had
control over the movement.
No single organization could
claim they were the
group that was running the
movement.
And while King is the most
electrifying speaker of this
great narrative, he hardly
had any control over it. If
you look to the events
of February 1st of 1960,
you can see the way in which
there was a sort of wildcat
mentality about many things
happening in the movement.
On that day, in
Greensboro, North Carolina,
four men, students of
North Carolina A&T,
black school, head to
downtown Greensboro,
not far away. They decide
that they're going to--sick
and tired of the treatment
they're receiving at the
Woolworth's, the
local five and dime,
let me think, drugstore,
convenience store. It's
funny, when I
began this course,
I mean when I began
teaching years ago,
Woolworth's were still
around. Ain't so much still
around anymore, but the, but
the history still is. So
the men go to the lunch
counter and insist on being
served. They could buy
things other places in the
store, but they couldn't
be served at the lunch
counter. The
waitress says, " I can't,
you know, I
can't help you out."
And they sit
there, and they sit,
and they sit, and they sit,
taking up four seats at the
lunch counter.
It's a wildcat sit-in.
It's not the first by
any stretch. The March on
Washington Movement had
been organizing them for
decades. Labor movements
have been organizing them
for decades. But
this time it takes off.
You have just the
right mix of electricity,
of anticipation, of
possibility and frustration
certainly.
And you see across the
country sit-ins by people
your age, all
across the South.
Sixty cities become
sites of sit-ins,
and all of these sit-ins,
the young men and women are
well dressed and impeccably
mannered. To do anything
else would invite potential
death. Ella Baker,
the person who's essentially
running the SCLC--King's the
head of it, but Ella
Baker's running it,
ministering it--taps into
this energy and organizes a
youth conference in
Raleigh, North Carolina,
in April. She's expecting
sort of a modest turnout.
Overwhelming turnout,
and overwhelming energy.
"We, the college age
students of the day,
need to do something. We
are ready." And out of that
organization grows
the Southern Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee,
otherwise known as SNCC.
I said Southern, I'm
sorry. Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee,
otherwise known as SNCC.
SNCC would never become the
biggest of the great civil
rights organizations,
but more than any,
any other organization, it
becomes the barometer of an
evolution, of the
evolution of 1960s ideology.
And SNCC will be part of, of
the narrative that I lay out
over the next two and a
half weeks of the course,
because through them,
you can actually see the
changes, and really
quite radical changes,
in movement ideology during
the 1960s. But at its
founding moment
in April in 1960,
SNCC is a group of
college-age individuals who
espoused
nonviolent ideology,
who are
absolutely interracial,
and who wanted to be
organized through a
non-hierarchical
system. They are,
from the beginning, seen as
a temporary organization,
literally given a corner
space in the offices of the
SCLC headquarters. So it
was operating under SCLC's
umbrella, SCLC thinking,
"This is a great way to get
more youth involved in our
movement." You could even
look back to the founding
moment and see there's
already some fissures
in the relationship,
if only because SNCC,
the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating
Committee, is committed to a
non-hierarchical
organ--organizing logic.
They, like Ella Baker, are
a little bit nervous in the
fact that SCLC is
embodied in King,
a magnificent man, but
a far from perfect man,
but only one man, and they
wanted an organization that
had many leaders. Now
that's April 1960. Heading
into the fall, in October,
King was arrested in Atlanta
for violating,
violating probation,
on trumped-up charges, and
he's sentenced to four--I
mean, I think it was
a traffic violation.
He's sentenced to four
months hard labor. John F.
Kennedy, who is campaigning
for the presidency,
calls Coretta Scott King and
says that he will protect
King. He actually had no
way of protecting King,
but in
orchestrated phone calls,
"I will do everything I can
to protect your husband."
And with that, black support
for Kennedy mushrooms.
Kennedy goes on to win by a
hundred and twenty thousand
votes--still debates whether
those votes actually existed
or not--but he won by a
hundred and twenty thousand
votes, and it's clear
that it's African American
support, support that swung
the election his direction.
Blacks have in JFK the kind
of leader at a symbolic and
cultural level they have not
had since FDR started making
these gestures towards
recognizing blacks' needs
some twenty-five, thirty
years earlier. In 1961--I'm
skipping a ton of details.
I'm trying to get up to a
moment of the most
famous crisis--in 1961,
CORE, the Congress
of Racial Equality,
as I mentioned in
the last lecture,
organizes a, a new
round of freedom rides,
getting on buses,
integrated riders,
and crossing state lines.
Members of SNCC are on the
bus as well.
Students from Yale,
from other places
in Connecticut,
jump on these buses and head
on South. Once they cross
into the Deep South, the
buses are attacked by smoke
bombs, tires are slashed.
As people run out of the
buses to get away
from the smoke,
they're met by mobs who
beat them with their fists,
with metal poles. The buses
are torched. Other buses
are sent down. Eventually,
the buses arrive down in
Birmingham, Alabama,
where Bull Connor,
the Commissioner
of Public Safety,
knows they're coming, knows
there's a mob waiting for
them at the bus station,
and does not offer police
protection, and
lets the students,
the riders, get beaten
senseless for fifteen
minutes before
letting the police come,
before releasing the police.
And people said, "Well, why
did you do such a thing?"
He goes, "It
was Mother's Day.
You can't take a man away
from his mother. You know,
they needed to have time
spent with their mother.
You know, they would get
there in time." There's a
dawning at this moment, with
this kind of violence and
recalcitrance, of a
militancy within SNCC and
the beginnings of a move
away from respectability.
You start seeing different
agendas being articulated
within different
organizations. The movement
is going in fits and
starts. Federations form
and break apart. There's
all kinds of infighting,
and things seemed on the
verge of collapse in Albany,
Georgia, when they go to
invoke another crisis. And
in Albany, Georgia, where
you have a confederation of
different civil rights
organizations coming
together, to try to
change that town,
they're outsmarted by
the white police. As the
students try to start
filling up the jails to
create a crisis of
overcrowding and,
and get national
sympathy, with the jail,
no bail strategy "We'll let
ourselves be in jail. We
won't accept bail. They'll
have to force us out. We
won't have paid any bail.
This will be great." The
police chief says, "We're
going to keep our heads and
start shuttling people out
of jails to other jails."
He doesn't react,
essentially. Nothing
happens.
Everything fizzles,
and there's a fear that
this movement that began,
quote, "began," in
quotes, with Brown v.
Board and has these violent
reactions as you see it with
Rosa Parks, and you
see it with Emmett Till,
and you see it in
Central High School,
the beginning of a new
sort of vibrant youth
organization, it feels like
it's all going to collapse
in Albany, Georgia, because
the white officers realized,
"If we don't react, this
thing will go away." Well,
thank god for Bull Connor.
I'll let the film tell you
much of that story, but
suffice it to say that
Connor did more,
through his brutality,
to help win converts to
the civil rights movement,
more than anybody else
could have practically done.
I'll pick up on that
moment, on that fact,
at the next
lecture. Thank you.